and a very great privilege to have
as our speaker tonight dr. Anthony fowey
the director of the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases at
NIH and I think easily one of the most
prominent scientists in this country
he's a man who literally needs no
introduction many of you have probably
already seen him on television or
elsewhere where he's emerged as one of
the most effective spokespeople and
educators in the area of infectious
diseases before I introduce dr. pouching
I just want to mention that the this is
sponsored by the hertog global strategy
initiative which is a research program
in the Department of History that
employs historical analysis to confront
fret present and future problems in
world politics and really ask the
question how can we learn from history
to have a better understanding of how to
deal with future problems what can
history teach us about the the future
next year's subject will be another one
of the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
religious violence and apocalyptic
movement so literally one of the four
horse people of the Apocalypse we thank
the her talk Foundation and Roger her
talk for their support of the program
the this program is also co-sponsored by
the Center for the history and ethics of
Public Health at the mailman School of
Public Health at Columbia University and
we're delighted to see the Melman school
is also very well represented tonight as
as well the global strategy seminar of
columbia university is also co-sponsor
and finally we are delighted to be able
to thank the public affairs department
the communications department at the
mailman school for the refreshments
which i hope you will all have a chance
or have had a chance to enjoy I also
hope and we all hope that you will come
back next year there is another speaker
next week as well but come back next
year for the
program on next year subject on
religious violence so it really is my
great pleasure and privilege to
introduce dr. falchi who's really been a
great visionary in the field of
infectious diseases indeed the idea of
emerging infections many of you may know
that the very first conference on the
subject was held by NIAID under AI ni AI
DS auspices in 1989 and led to what has
now become an almost an industry and
emerging infections and emerging viruses
which was the original subject of that
conference dr. fowey became director of
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases just as the hiv/aids
epidemic was beginning and so has been
the director through many interesting
and obviously very challenging times
recently people have spoken about the
hiv/aids epidemic at 30 it was
recognized just about 30 years ago now
and dr. foul he became director of the
Institute in 1984 and has really been
very effective in educating and
obviously developing research programs
on HIV and many other infectious
diseases so I won't take much time with
a formal introduction since I think
you'll have a lot of interesting things
to tell us only to mention that he is
also a graduate of the Cornell now Weill
Cornell Medical School and a specialist
in infectious diseases and still works
actively in the field of immunology and
immunologic research where you find the
time I have absolutely no idea of being
so busy obviously with this very
important position as director so it is
my pleasure to present dr. Tony fowey
who'll talk about 30 years of hiv/aids a
personal journey
thank you very much Steve it's a really
a pleasure to be here with you this
afternoon to talk about this
extraordinary subject I think it's very
appropriate for me to address this
audience with the interest that I know
permeates so many people in the audience
from a couple of standpoints as many of
you know HIV was first recognized not
the virus but the disease itself as a
new syndrome in the summer of nineteen
eighty-one so that's exactly 30 years
ago and number two I want to talk to you
about and I use the terminology a
personal journey because it really has
been an extraordinary personal journey
for me being one of the few people I
believe who was there and began working
on this literally from the very first
weeks of the recognition that we were
dealing with something unusual and I'll
tell you the story about that as part of
this personal journey and as someone who
is still working on this so I have an
unusual experience for better or for
worse of having been through essentially
every day of those 30 years and as I
mentioned to the students just a little
while ago in a very enjoyable meeting I
had with with some of the students that
what's going to come in and out of this
discussion is going to be the issue that
what happens to you and your
professional career is is very often
unrelated to anything that you do it's
just almost bite by accident you have to
be well prepared I believe you have to
be reasonably smart you can't be a dummy
and do good things unless you're really
lucky but its opportunities that come
your way and I'm going to talk a little
bit about them
we've them in to this story of my
personal journey through this historic
pandemic so it didn't start off in the
summer of nineteen eighty one I had an
interest obviously in medicine and as as
Steve mentioned I went to Cornell
University Medical College and did my
internship and residency there and
here's a picture of me as an intern
actually at the New York Hospital in
medicine spent a few years there and
then I had an interest in infectious
diseases and the interface between
infectious disease and immunology so you
may ask okay that's nice who cares but
the interface of infectious diseases and
immunology was something that I could
not have predicted would have poised me
to be a in a very interesting position
to study a syndrome that I didn't
imagine would occur at that time as I
was doing my internship and residency so
I went down to the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases at the
National Institutes of Health so why did
I do that well when I graduated medical
school and did my internship and the
residency and this is one of maybe six
or seven things that happened to me that
would completely beyond my control we
were in the middle of a war the Vietnam
War and we all got drafted so I got
drafted like everybody else did but one
that we were a physician we were asked
to prioritize whether you wanted to go
into the Public Health Service the army
the Navy of the Air Force I was
interested in infectious diseases so I
said put the Public Health Service I'd
go to either the cdc gov the NIH if I
didn't get that i put the navy second
the army third and the Air Force fourth
no offense to people who served in the
lower group there but that's what I did
as it turned out I was accepted in the
Public Health Service and that's why I
went to Bethesda as opposed to doing a
residency and a fellowship and
infectious disease at Cornell completely
beyond my control point number one so I
went to the ni
h and i had some interesting experiences
with some extraordinary people one of
the most important of which was a fellow
who was my mentor a fellow named Shelley
wolf Sheldon wolf who nobody in this
room I would expect to know but he put
me on projects that I almost was not
deserving to be on because they were
very exciting projects that had nothing
to do with infectious diseases they had
to do with immunologically mediated
diseases like wegener's granulomatosis
and the vascular duties which was the
early part of my career that I was
fortunate enough to make some
significant contributions to again look
just threw it in my way I did a three
year fellowship at the National
Institutes of Health and I came back to
the New York Hospital to be chief
resident in medicine and here's a
picture of me notice the hair is
different you could always tell what
year it is look at somebody's hair and
their glasses wire-rim glasses long hair
1970s so I did that for a year and then
came back to the NIH and got involved
for about ten years in a group of
projects that were highly successful and
and I want to take a moment particularly
for the younger people in the audience
to tell you about how you make decisions
and you're not really sure why you make
decisions I started studying these
inflammatory diseases and by chance two
floors up from my hospital at the nih in
bethesda was a person named vince davido
& paul Carbone who would developing
independently the cure for Hodgkin's
disease and acute lymphoblastic leukemia
they were good friends of mine and they
were using combination chemotherapy one
of the drugs with cyclophosphamide so I
was studying a non-malignant
inflammatory disease that was a hundred
percent lethal so we got the idea if we
use cyclophosphamide in a high enough
dose to suppress the immune system but
not so high as to kill the patient and
wipe out their bone marrow
maybe we could shut off this disease
which was wagging his granulomatosis of
vasculitis as it turns out we developed
the cure for the disease so at 27 years
old I was in the entirely unlikely
situation of having made a major
contribution in medicine so I thought
that was my career that's where I'm
going but it wasn't infectious diseases
and I have been fascinated by infectious
diseases in global health so despite
this great accomplishment at a young age
I was as they say a restless about what
I wanted to do then one day in June of
1981 this landed on my desk at the NIH
in Bethesda it was a report of five
otherwise healthy gay men from Los
Angeles who are presenting with a
bizarre pneumonia called Pneumocystis
pneumonia now most people didn't have
any idea what pneumocystis pneumonia was
I happen to because I had gotten my
boards in infectious diseases and I was
the infectious disease consult for the
patients on the Cancer Institute who
were getting chemotherapy for cancer and
every once in a while because their
immune system was suppressed they wound
up getting pneumocystis so I was very
familiar i was thinking us of why five
gay men otherwise healthy getting
pneumocystis pneumonia I thought it was
a curiosity I threw it on another part
of my desk one month later the fourth of
July of 1981 another report from the CDC
now 26 interestingly all gay men not
only from LA but from New York City and
from San Francisco who presented not
only with pneumocystis pneumonia but
with also an unusual cancer called kappa
xi sarcoma now i know many people in the
room know this but this never occurs in
someone
with a healthy immune system so I said
to myself much and then I i announced it
much to the chagrin and the advice of my
mentors and colleagues i decided that i
was going to stop studying inflammatory
diseases and devote my immediate
energies turn into admitting these gay
men with this strange disease called
gay-related immune deficiency at the
time my memphis thought i was nuts they
said here you are you're a young man
you're relatively famous as a physician
why are you giving it up to study this
disease that's only affecting very few
men who are in a very restricted
epidemiological population well that
winter published the following spring in
the annals of internal medicine in 1982
long before we even knew that HIV was
the cause of the virus I wrote a
commentary for the annals of internal
medicine called the syndrome of kappa
she sarcoma and opportunistic infections
and epidemiologically restricted order
of this immunoregulation it wasn't even
called AIDS yet and one of my quotes
from that paper was because we do not
know the cause of this syndrome any
assumption that the syndrome will remain
restricted to a particular segment of
our society is truly an assumption
without scientific basis and i was
actually criticized by that as being an
alarmist and there were a couple of
newspaper comments about this as this
infectious disease person at the nih was
being alarmist by suggesting that this
was going to spread well beyond the
restricted gay communities in the big
cities well then month by month and year
by year soon after that remember the
article was published in june in july
kappa she saw comer among haitians
norma's
justice when the hemophiliacs
transfusion associated disease
unexplained arise in infants we didn't
know that their mothers were infected at
the time inman deficiency among female
sexual partners of males with acquired
immunodeficiency so it started to
unravel in a way that quite frankly we
all know now retrospectively was truly
historic in the annals of global health
and infectious diseases so here's a
picture of me on rounds in the NIH
hospital admitting patients in which
it's a very unusual feeling that it's
difficult to describe when you bring in
patients you have no idea what's causing
their illness and they all die so I've
described that as the very dark years of
my career but I had to do something so
how to do research so we my laboratory
before aids was an immunological
laboratory and we were studying b-cells
so we had a fellow in my lab a very
young man who was coming in for a
fellowship named cliff Lane and I said
cliff why don't we start studying B
cells in hiv-infected individuals and we
did and we found out something that is a
major paradox that despite
immunodeficiency there's an aberrant
activation of cells this was the first
paper before HIV was even discovered
that indicated that a barren immune
activation was a major pathogenic
feature of HIV and now 30 years later as
some of you may know who are in the
field a barren immune activation is the
driving force that allows for virus
replication so this was a serendipitous
finding that I had no idea what it meant
but god bless the new england journal of
medicine they allowed me to publish it
even though i didn't have an explanation
for it next came the first description
of the antigen defect now I'm not going
to say anything else at all for the
remainder of the
talk about any research that I've done
over the last 30 years for HIV because
what i want to tell you is a heck of a
lot more interesting i think then giving
you a list of papers that i published so
let's go through the evolution of this
interesting story i hated administration
i'm a clinician and a bench scientist
but i was clear to me that the response
of this country and the research
community to HIV was not adequate so the
director of NIAID retired that year
Richard Crowley still a dear friend and
I was asked to become the director of
NIAID and I was as it turned out the
youngest director that they've ever had
at the NIH I didn't want to do it but I
said to myself even though I don't
particularly like administration maybe I
could have be put myself in a role that
will have some influence not only in HIV
but in infectious diseases and global
health in general so I made that choice
which retrospectively clearly was the
right choice that put me in a world that
I took to but was not trained for and
this is a picture of me testifying
before the Congress of the United States
so I went back to my congressional
colleagues and asked them to look in the
Congressional Record and I find that
with HIV and what we've done with SARS
and West nylon h5n1 and h1n1 I have the
world's indoor record of testifying
before Congress for 210 times in the
last 30 some-odd years so it's it's an
interesting phenomenon I've been beaten
up by some of the best congressmen and
Senators in the country now the other
thing that was very important that put
me in an arena that I'll ever would have
imagined is that because of the nature
of the problem I got to have what i call
interacting with presidents and it was a
very interesting experience that i'd
like to just share some anecdotes with
you because they are clearly true but
they are not the kind of
that you would expect the first person
that I developed a relationship was with
Ronald Reagan now Ronald Reagan as you
know was vilified and I think partially
justifiably for his reluctance to be
public about HIV to come out and say we
have a problem we need to do something
about it and he did that likely because
he didn't want to offend his
conservative base but what he did do
that people don't know is that he
allowed me and personally discussed it
with me and Jim Curran and others at the
CDC to go out and really try and figure
out what was going on with this pandemic
which we did we didn't get a lot of
money for it but we went out to the bad
houses and in San Francisco into the
crack houses and Brooklyn and looked
around try to figure out just what was
going on here it was readily apparent it
was a sexually in blood-borne infectious
diseases you didn't need to be a genius
to figure that out but there wasn't
major administration interest in it
however when George HW Bush was vice
president and decided to run for the
presidency he realized that HIV would be
an important problem so he wanted to
know about it so for the last few years
I had been doing nothing but HIV so he
called up the Secretary of HHS and said
I heard that this god this guy's out she
down at the NIH is doing HIV stuff is
there any chance we can go down and
visit the NIH and here's him when he was
vice president visiting and he became
extremely interested in it and that was
the first big blip in the budget to my
great honor I developed a friendship
with him when he was vice president
which set a rule for me that i'm going
to give you several examples for when
you're in Washington be nice to
everybody because you never know where
they're ultimately going to land so he
for reasons that I still can't explain
he still communicates with me by
by his handwritten notes in such a
wonderful warm way he became fascinated
with that and we became good friends
when he became president he visited the
NIH several times and built up the
funding at my and the assistance of
others for HIV research and he did the
same thing for the CDC so here's Kim
visiting with mrs. Bush on a separate
visit he wanted to get to understand the
whole issue of what it feels like to be
HIV infected so we thought we would
introduce him to a bunch of patients so
here he is you may not see it well where
we generally have the patients have some
recreational time and all of these
individuals here here I'm here are
hiv-infected individuals so I'm sitting
here he's talking with them the second
example of the rule when you're in
Washington be nice to everybody because
sitting here in this corner is somebody
that you might recognize and that was
george w bush who was a staffer at the
White House with his father before he
became the general manager and owner of
the Texas Rangers and then ultimately
the governor of Texas and in my new role
of being nice to everybody I was really
nice with him and we developed a
friendship even before he became the
president and the reason I tell you the
story is going to become extremely
relevant in a few minutes when I tell
you how things evolved President Clinton
again was very very interested in that
and took an interest a lot in the
science because you know what you read
about Clinton he is a wonky kind of guy
in the Science in fact when he invited
me to the Oval Office subsequent to this
to talk about HIV I asked his chief of
staff it was Leon Panetta at the time
what did he want to hear like a broad
epidemiological study or did he want to
hear about the science so of course
Clinton said I want to hear about the
sign
Here I am in the Oval Office explaining
to him the interaction between the HIV
envelope and cd4 and the ccr5 receptor
because the ccr5 receptor had just been
discovered and published like the
previous year and from the look in his
eye he was asking his typical question
well what do you think about that
receptor this is Al Gore who I know is
thinking that I must have discovered
this receptor no but it was just kidding
just a joke I'm sorry example 3 of when
in Washington be nice to everybody
because this is a picture of Hillary
Clinton when she was the first lady and
we developed a very fond relationship
which was extremely helpful when she
became the senator from New York and now
the Secretary of State and we'll get
into that when we talk a little bit
about the Global Health Initiative this
is george w bush which will get back to
in a moment who rekindled his interest
in this when he came back as president
and obviously president obama here
visiting me and Francis Collins at the
NIH had the opportunity to discuss with
him some of the issues the unfortunate
issue with President Obama is that he
now is living in an arena of
extraordinary constraints on resources
so although everyone would like to have
an explosion of resources it's going to
be very very difficult to do and I'll
get into that in a second so that's the
background of it so let's take a look at
from that first MMWR where there were 26
plus five patients to where we are right
now the new numbers have just come out
from the CDC and the UN aids 65 million
people were infected with HIV about 30
plus million have died 34 million living
with HIV 2.6 million new infections a
year 1.8 million deaths and as I
mentioned the cumulative lee 30 million
deaths 1.8 per year
so if you do the math on this when used
to hiv/aids because we've been living
with it for 30 years but historically
it's one of the most impactful pandemics
in the history of our civilization if
you compare it with anything bubonic
plague smallpox measles the pandemic of
1918 it ranks on that short list in the
United States we become complacent there
are about 600,000 deaths interestingly
1.2 million people are living with HIV
importantly twenty percent of them don't
know they're infected and fifty percent
of all new infections come from a person
who doesn't know that he or she is
infected that inadvertently infects
somebody else so this is a group that we
haven't gotten to so in 2009 still male
to male MNOs sex with men still is the
major risk category the striking thing
that some of you may have read the New
York Times yesterday when Don McNeil
wrote about the CDC's new numbers that
the incident rate among
african-americans is eight times higher
than among whites and although we're
stable at 50,000 new infections each
year there is an increase among black
men who have sex with men so in 2011 in
the gay black population in the United
States the incidence is increasing get
that it's not stable and it's not going
down it's increasing so we cannot hope
we have a question period later I'd like
to get into why those things that happen
but I'll leave it for a little
discussion later so the NIH research
funding has been extraordinary this is
what it was early on and then this would
happen when I told you we finally were
able to have a person to person dialogue
with george HW bush and with subsequent
presidents so now
the NIH has cumulatively spent 45
billion dollars that's on AIDS research
alone and it's about ten percent of our
budget the NIH budget is about 30 1
billion we spend about 3.1 billion
dollars a year on AIDS research so there
is an extraordinary effort when you put
that much resources in you get results
there have been now I show this is
interesting i did a search three days
ago so if you plug in HIV you get
228,000 papers that were published i
must confess i haven't read every one of
them but i've looked at the titles of
every one of them I've read most of them
but not all of them but what that really
yielded was extraordinary advances in
science etiology diagnosis natural
history but nowhere nowhere has there
been as great an impact as in the arena
of treatment which tells you when
there's a will to get a therapy for a
disease you can get it so let's go back
to discussion of the treatment of HIV
infected individuals will go back to my
making rounds on my wards in 1981 so
this is a picture of me in the fall of
nineteen eighty one with an HIV infected
individual I mentioned to you that that
was the dark years of my medical career
it's very difficult to describe because
remember the reason I told you that
little anecdote about developing the
cure for inflammatory diseases before 10
years of my life every patient that came
in with a lethal disease we used the
Falchi protocol and they walked out of
the hospital and they hugged me and said
you've saved my life and it was really a
great hard to be on for the next 10
years it was exactly the opposite is
that people came in and instead of being
a healer we were healing nobody six to
eight months was the median survival
back in the 1980s in 1987 the first
glimmer of hope this is the new england
journal of medicine paper showing
that when you used a ZT in hiv-infected
individuals versus a placebo over the
period of 24 weeks of the study 19
people on placebo died one person on AZT
died this was the first and the only
placebo-controlled trial of therapy and
HIV for obvious reasons you can't
ethically do a trial when you have a
treatment number one number two it was
the fastest approved antiviral or
antibiotic in the history of the FDA now
everybody was on a high because we now
had a drug it was short-lived because
what we kind of realized but didn't
admit when you have a highly replicated
RNA virus it will mutate and it will
develop resistance and that's exactly
what happened but that didn't stop the
research community this is the
replication cycle of HIV with Fusion
entry reverse transcription integration
and then budding using the enzyme
protease we've now over the last 26
years that we've been trying to develop
drugs have drugs for each of these
targets and we have now 31 fda-approved
drugs which as many of you know when
used in combination have completely
transformed the lives of hiv-infected
individuals so that in the same building
that I showed you where I was at the
bedside of the patient where the only
thing I could tell their relatives is
that they'll likely be dead in six to
eight months now if the same person
comes into that same building and let's
say is a 25 year old who's newly
infected with HIV and I stop them on a
triple combination like a tripler or
some similar combination you can
mathematically predict that they will
live in a
50 50 years so that may be one of the
most important accomplishments of the
translation of fundamental basic
research to a therapy for a globally
important disease now I can't talk about
treatment or AIDS without talking about
the role of activism so I want to get
back there was a reason for the Ronald
Reagan slide so remember during the
early eighties I told you Reagan said
I'm not going to get up despite the fact
that Elizabeth Taylor dissed him really
badly for not doing that because there
were good friends he didn't get up and
talk about AIDS but he told me and Jim
Curran and how Jaffe and the people at
the NIH that go ahead and do that this
is an important problem so accidentally
I became the face of the federal
government because I was in the
newspapers I was on television a lot so
when they thought aids federal
government ouchy so when the gay
community started to realize that the
government was not responding
appropriately enough they started to do
something that in and of itself is
historic in a very very positive way so
here's a picture of somebody that some
of you may recognize his name is Larry
Kramer he is a award-winning playwright
screenwriter he was nominated for an
Oscar for writing the screenplay of
women in love he just won three Emmys
for his play on Broadway that's still
running called a normal heart he decided
that he wanted to get the attention of
the federal government ie me even though
I wasn't the federal government so he
engaged in a bunch of theatrical
maneuvers that were really quite
effective he as some of you may know
started act up New York and is the
co-founder of gay men's health crisis so
he has a very strong commitment to the
gay community
he was the it's a very interesting i
have to tell you this even though
because this is part of my personal
journey he wrote a book called the
in the 1970s now the was
a book about the sexual revolution among
gay men and the bathhouse culture and as
a gay man he warned that we didn't know
what it was that if they continue to
have completely uninhibited promiscuous
sex they're going to get an infectious
disease or diseases that's going to
destroy them he said that in the 70s he
was completely vilified by the gay
community who thought that they were
that he was trying to put a damper on
their newly found sexual freedom he went
on to write a number of plays this is
the normal heart that's on Broadway
interestingly the destiny of me I got to
know him very well I'm jumping ahead of
myself the destiny of me is a play in
which I'm a character in the play and my
wife is the nurse in the play he called
me Tony della vita Tony of life and it
was a story about a doctor who is a
complete incompetent idiot which was me
all right so what he actually did more
than that he wanted to get our attention
so in the San Francisco Chronicle in
June of 1988 in the magazine section on
the cover I called you murderers and
open letter to an incompetent idiot dr.
Anthony falchi of the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases that
was his way of saying I don't think the
government is paying enough attention to
HIV and AIDS so a movement began that
was a wonderful movement now in
retrospect then I'm going to tell you a
minute or two about it the FDA and the
scientific community were extremely
rigid in looking at a disease in which
everybody had a mean survive median
survival of six to eight months and
treating it like hypertension will do a
clinical trial will exclude you for this
it'll take seven years to approve the
drug they were saying no you can't do
that so they were very very concerned
about the slow
and the rigidity of getting into a
clinical trial which means that if you
have a drug that you haven't proven
works but you want to at least have a
chance because you know all your friends
are dying you want access to that but
the FDA rules and even the scientists
rules are I'm sorry these are the entry
criteria for the clinical trial so many
many people were excluded they wanted to
change that so here they are
demonstrating in front of the FDA this
was prior to their becoming
sophisticated they knew that I was a
scientist they thought I worked at the
FDA so they demonstrated at the FDA with
dr. fowey you are killing us by not
making drugs available when they found
out that I had nothing to do with the
NFTA and I was actually at the NIH they
said let's storm the NIH so they just
happen to have a wrong property they
were in rockville instead of Bethesda
but what's the difference so here is
them outside of the window of our
building with smoke bombs and lying down
with a die-in in front of our offices at
the NIH then I did something and I tell
you the truth I'm not sure exactly why I
did it I just did it the Montgomery
County police and the NIH police and the
FBI were on the campus because this was
turning into a mini riot and they were
going to arrest everybody so I came down
from my office and I spoke to the police
and I said don't arrest anybody get five
people who can be representative and
bring him up to my office and I'll talk
to them about some of their concerns
because I had been reading and listening
to what they were saying and it was
making perfect sense but because of the
theater of what they were doing they
completely turned off the established
scientific community who is never
amenable to being questioned about what
we do particularly when it's by somebody
with dressed in goth clothing with a few
theorems and a mohawk haircut it just
one
the hills so I said come up to my office
and we'll talk and we had a conversation
which was the first time that anybody
ever sat down and spoke with the
activists and I got to tell you
retrospectively it was one of the best
things that I've ever done because from
that dialogue came a give-and-take among
the activists and the federal government
where they are now an important
component of every clinical trial that
we design on every protocol that we do
the activists are involved in the design
including on the FDA advisory committees
so you can't talk about hiv/aids without
talking about the importance of activism
I almost lost my job and I'll tell you
the story of this this is Marty Delaney
who is a gay activist from San Francisco
who was much more cerebral and
intellectual than Larry Kramer who was
just iconoclastic and he was fighting
for what's called parallel track which
means that if you start a clinical trial
and you restrict the entry because you
can only have a certain number of people
in a clinical trial don't exclude people
who don't have access have a parallel
track where with an informed consent you
won't interfere with the integrity of
the trial but you'll allow other people
to have access it was called parallel
track and he was on the phone convincing
me that I should come out publicly
against this the FDA was completely
against it totally against it
understandably with all due respect to
them they're good people but they were
against this he convinced me to be for
it so he invited me to San Francisco to
see some of the people who are infected
with HIV and to learn a little bit more
about the castro community so we spent a
half a day in the Castro and then he put
me in a town hall meeting in downtown
San Francisco right off union square and
he got I got
up and he said Tony what do you come out
please and be publicly for the parallel
track well I did what I didn't know is
that there was a New York Times reporter
in the first row so I came out and it
says AIDS researcher seeks wide access
and this is exactly from the new york
times article in a major shift sought by
those involved in the fight against aids
the chief of federal research in aids
has called for a new system that would
allow patients far greater access to
experimental drugs I call this a
parallel attract to clinical trials so
when I was flying back on the red-eye
from San Francisco and land that I saw
this in the New York Times and I
immediately got multiple calls from the
Department of Health and Human Services
saying that I was in serious trouble
make a long story short I wasn't getting
back to be friends with anybody the
President of the United States at the
time was george HW bush and i got to
convince him that actually parallel
track was the way to go and he took it
so I didn't lose my job and the FDA came
out the next day saying what a wonderful
idea this is they actually did it was
amazing so let's fast forward now in
activism the activists in the 80s were
demonstrating to have access to drugs
that were not proven to be effective yet
but they wanted a chance in Africa which
really reached the head in the Durban
meeting of the International AIDS
Society in two thousand they borrowed a
page from the gay activist playbook and
said we want drugs because we now know
they work so why don't we have access
and it was a feeling i think it was
submerged subconscious racism or
something that didn't think you could
actually go to Africa and treat people
in Africa every day for a disease or
they wouldn't take their medications
which as we know now is total nonsense
so that gets to the birth of PEPFAR so I
want to tell you about
everybody knows about PEPFAR tell you
how PEPFAR came about president george w
bush in 2002 sent this is tommy thompson
who was the secretary of HHS at the time
and me to Africa and asked me the
question he said he brought me into his
office in the Roosevelt Room and said I
want you to go to Africa and I want you
to figure out something that could be a
game-changer something that we could do
for developing nations particularly
African maybe the Caribbean which could
actually turn around and give them
something that we as a rich nation have
an obligation to do now for the people
who hate george w bush you wouldn't
believe that he said that but he said
that so tommy thompson and i went to
sub-saharan africa and we stopped at a
bunch of countries to see if it would be
feasible to do that and in Africa
particularly in a place like Uganda
there was organizations like the aids
service organization or tasso which alex
katina was the head of at the time so in
one of my delving into the community
there I wanted to see if you can
actually implement the program so here's
me it's a dark you can't see it making
rounds in a hospital in Kampala and I
was it was it was sort of the worst deja
vu I ever had because these guys these
African doctors were me in 1981 they had
the patients who had the disease they
had no drugs for them the difference is
drugs existed but they didn't have them
with me there were no drugs we just
didn't have him so what we did is we
went into the community here's me with a
young 19 year old woman who works at the
aid service organization and she said
with Alex coutinho's go ahead take me
into the bush and see that you can
actually get drugs to people who are in
rural areas so here's her on a
motorcycle I took this picture from the
Land Rover behind there she took me to
the villages here we are in a
College where they must have been about
twelve percent of the village was
infected in three or four of these
children were also infected there but
she was delivering drugs so I went back
to Washington and I worked for several
months with staff members some of you
may recognize again I hate to repeat it
but it's true be nice to everybody
because when George HW Bush was the
president a low-level staffer that was
working in the White House was a person
named Josh Bolten and Josh Bolten
ultimately turned out to be the chief of
staff to the president and there is no
less powerful person than the chief of
staff to the president so when I came
back to Washington the president asked
me to work with Josh Bolten in trying to
figure out a formula that could put
billions of dollars to prevent treat and
care for hiv-infected individuals but
his one mandate to me the president's
mandate was it's got to be a
game-changing it's got to be accountable
he refused to be giving money to
individual countries because he thought
they were just going to suck up the
money and nothing good was going to
happen so I spent about seven months
from around june till around the end of
december the beginning of january going
back and forth with different versions
and the president called it the
chevrolet version the oldsmobile version
and the mercedes version and the
mercedes version was the most expensive
one so we finally put it together and
was getting ready to present it but it
would cost 15 billion dollars so i got a
real taste of washington hardball
because oh and be the Office of
Management and the budget which is the
original description of know that you
can't do it because it's too expensive
they were dead set against me and we're
really in many respects I can say it now
not Owen being general because the
people who were there are no longer
there we're really trying to undermine
this effort saying you're going to
convince the President to spend 15
billion dollars so I did that and I went
back and forth and back
fani to say we're close to it but we
need some outside verification so they
said what we want you to do we want you
to get for people who are actually on
the ground doing this who will testify
that your formula this was a big
mathematical model will work but we
wanted here in 48 hours so how do you do
that so I said the four people that I
know I got on the phone I called a poor
farmer who was in Haiti at the time i
called up Eric Goosby the current
ambassador who is in Rwanda at the time
I called bill pop who's a Haitian and
Peter McGann ye who is the Ugandan
doctor and I said the White House was
very very secretive we want you to bring
him here but we can't tell you can't
tell them why they're coming and I said
how do you get somebody to come 5,000
10,000 miles and says it well you got to
get him so I got on the phone he said
trust me come to Washington and I can't
tell you why but it's really going to be
very important now all of these four
people were pushing for universal access
so they kind of suspected why I was
bringing them to Washington so they came
to Washington and I wasn't supposed to
prep them I just was supposed to bring
them to the white house so that mitch
Daniels who was the head of OMB would
find out if this was really something
crazier was workable so I I told a white
lie I told him that I would not talk to
them before but I lied I took them to a
restaurant in bethesda i want to show
you this picture because this is the
restaurant where paul farmer and I and
pete him again ii and others when i
briefed them about what was going on and
what did we say this reminded me of that
restaurant in the Bronx that Michael
Corleone's shots the loss of the Turk
and the police captain remember in The
Godfather was just looked just like that
restaurant nobody got shot but they went
they convinced OMB and the president in
his state of the union address declared
the development of PEPFAR and that's
history you know now that PEPFAR as of
just this past fall 3.2 million people
are receiving a
these 114,000 infants who would have
been infected or not infected the mother
to child transmission and 11 million
people are receiving care if you add
PEPFAR the Global Fund and
philanthropies there are currently today
6.6 million people whose lives are being
saved in the lower middle-income
countries because of the availability of
drugs I'm going to get back to that in a
second because this is the challenge of
the future because despite the fact that
6.6 million people are being treated and
the life expectancy this is a study from
Uganda has major league increases that's
the good news the sobering news is that
only forty percent of the people who
could benefit from it in lower
middle-income countries are receiving it
and catastrophic alee for every one
person we put on therapy two to three
people get newly infected which means
what prevention which is really the
thing that we're emphasizing now so I'm
going to tell you one more story and
then we'll just go and finish and have
some questions the story is you can't
talk about prevention without talking
about this person anybody recognize this
guy you Oh Becca you're old enough this
is C everett Koop who interestingly i
love washington because it's such a
living paradox C everett Koop was
brought from Pennsylvania where he was
the chief of the chopped the Children's
Hospital of Pennsylvania surgery he was
felt to be a conservative because he
fought for the lives of kids who had
deformities he did operation he
separated the first Siamese twin
operation so they brought him to
Washington because they thought he'd
this is Ronald Reagan now brings them to
Washington because he thought that he
was an arch-conservative so the Liberals
in Washington decided they were going to
block his nomination so paradox of all
paradoxes Teddy Kennedy and others were
trying to block him he was going through
some very very difficult stress he came
to Washington and seven months went by
and he had multiple hearings and all
they did was blast
because they didn't want to approve him
as the Surgeon General however the
Surgeon General and inside the beltway
secret lives on the campus of the NIH so
C everett Koop was felt that he was
getting very very nervous and tense his
blood pressure was up so he asked for a
doctor so they said Oh Tony thought
she's a pretty good doctor he'll take
care of you so I became she overcooks
personal physician and I went over men
people were putting him on a lot I told
him I was going to tell you this story
so I'm not diverging anything divulging
anything I shouldn't so he was all these
medications and what he really had was
you know he was just totally wiped out
and stressed so I made after about a
month of worked him up I worked him up
from stem to stern and I made the
diagnosis of him and is a very common
diagnosis it's the welcome to Washington
traumatic stress disorder so I got him
off all those medications and we became
very good friends so this is my desk at
the NIH and this is his house you could
see it right out my window so every
evening or not every evening that's
hyperbole maybe twice a week he went on
his way home stop in my office I used to
work till nine o'clock at night and so
he i was there and he said tell me about
this aids thing maybe he's a surgeon who
knows nothing about AIDS he became
fascinated with AIDS he became a scholar
on AIDS here's a picture of he and I in
his office this was years later right
before he was getting ready to retire
till the point where he knew so much
about it that he said he wanted to write
a public surgeon general's report on
aids as well as a letter to every
household on AIDS and he did that the
only trouble is the conservatives in
Washington got really upset that this
would go out so they didn't give him any
money to publish it so for those of you
have been any of you have been to the
NIH there's a thing called an
interagency agreement which means I have
the legal authority to sign over a
limited amount of money to another
agency so I gave him to
$50,000 from my budget to put out the
surgeon general's report he did much to
the dismay of a lot of people because he
said in the report things like gay men
anal sex oral sex injection drug use to
the point that i'm going to show you a
very representative cartoon that
appeared right after the surgeon
general's report came out there's a
woman going to work and says if anything
comes in the mail from the Surgeon
General don't open it so that was the
story of prevention so what about
prevention there are a number of
prevention modalities that absolutely
work the real issue is to implement them
and they are listed here everything from
clean syringes use of condoms
pre-exposure prophylaxis mother to child
transmission we now have within our
armamentarium what it takes to turn
around the HIV pandemic this is the
efficacy of circumcision in an African
study almost seventy percent effective
between uncircumcised and circumcised if
we had a vaccine that was sixty-eight
percent effective it would get approved
like that and yet we don't have the
money to fully implement circumcision
programs in Africa we know that topical
microbicides work we know that if you
take a gel and and and and embed it with
todavia depending on the adherence you
can significantly block the spread of
HIV to heterosexual women we know that
pre exposure prophylaxis works in a
study and men who have sex with men I
just want to take 30 seconds to tell you
of the importance of adherence to a
modality that works so the overall
reduction was forty-four percent in all
men and this is uninfected men who have
sex with men you give them a pill of
Tanaka via once a day or trovato
forty-four percent efficacy if you ask
them if they take their medication and
they say yeah I tick it or not and you
only can
the people who admitted that they took
their medication the efficacy was
seventy two percent if you said I still
don't believe you and you draw their
blood and you compare those who have a
blood level with those who have a not a
blood level the efficacy is ninety-one
percent which tells you that you can
have an effective therapy but if they
don't take it or an effective
prophylaxis it's not going to work
that's key in how we're going to
approach the AIDS pandemic there were
two randomized trials that we that was
presented in Rome that pre-exposure
prophylaxis works among heterosexuals we
thought it would only be in gay men know
it works in whether you're the
uninfected sexual partner a woman or a
man it works what about treatment as
prevention this is probably the most
important thing that has occurred in
aids clinical trials in the last decade
there has always been a tension between
resources for prevention and resources
for treatment now we know these studies
suggested it in cohort studies decreased
community viral load in San Francisco
heterosexual cohorts in Vancouver
injection drug users if you treat people
the rate of infection goes down in the
community a study was recently published
that showed that if you look at the
scored and couples in which one person
is infected and the other one is not and
you treat the infected person and bring
their viral load down to essentially
below detectable level there's a
ninety-six percent decrease in the risk
of transmitting infection to the
uninfected partner this is it folks the
more people you treat the more
infections you're going to prevent and
that's really going to be the driving
force now of being very aggressive in
this regard there is a study that is
looking at the feasibility of what we
call testing voluntary testing linking
to care and treating in a study that's a
three-year study that started
which is a study that has six cities but
two of which other keen to key cities is
the South Bronx and the leader of that
study is sitting right there while fell
sada who does it in the South Bronx and
the people in Washington DC to see if in
fact it's going to be feasible to get to
the community to get them voluntarily
tested I'm going to close on a vaccine
we've been searching for a vaccine for
about 24 years the first positive result
came from a trial in Thailand it
certainly is not ready for prime time it
was only thirty one percent effective
but it proved the contact the concept
that we can't have a vaccine right now
we're getting much more sophisticated
about it by structure-based vaccine
design I want to spend literally 30
seconds of this because this if I gave
you the details of this this can be very
heavy and dense what we've found out is
that certain rare individuals make
broadly reacting neutralizing antibodies
to important epitopes this is the
envelope spike particularly the CD for
combining site the trouble is we don't
make it readily easily and we make it
too late so the challenge for
vaccinology is how do you get these
epitopes and make an epitope into an
immunogen so that when you vaccinate
somebody they actually do make broadly
reacting neutralizing antibodies so the
future is going to be and this is very
unusual it breaks the paradigm of normal
infectious diseases and that is that
there's going to be no uni-dimensional
way to prevent HIV it's going to be
different for different populations so
what we're thinking about now in the
absence of a vaccine is a combination of
HIV prevention modalities when we get a
vaccine which I hope we will it will be
one of the combinations importantly is
this treatment as prevention so every
time you treat an HIV infected
individual you remove from the cul
a potential spreader of infection so the
days of the tension between treatment
and prevention should be put behind us
so this is a picture of me last week at
the rome meeting where I was addressing
the the assembly thereof about 6,000
people were there and I just want to
close by leaving you with the message
that i left them after 30 years of
reflecting about where we are we have
enormous scientific advances it is time
now and I know we have constrained
resources but just like the activists
put the pressure on us in the 1980s you
know as a responsible community we need
to put the pressure on to implement the
scientific advances namely we know what
we need to do to get our arms around
this pandemic and we're not going to
wait for a vaccine science magazine was
kind enough to allow me to summarize in
600 words my prediction for what we need
to do and i published an article a few
weeks ago in science and editorial but i
just want to close this discussion with
what i said in that article it's
entitled let science and foreign policy
and it's just what i said we now have an
unprecedented opportunity based on
science often scientific data to control
and ultimately end the AIDS pandemic
major investments in implementation now
will save even greater expenditures in
the future and in the meantime countless
lives can be saved thank
thank you very much the floor is now
open for questions I'm sure there will
be many and there's a microphone in the
center of the room thank you for your
presentation I'd like to go back into
the question of education up there that
you had I know many people who both
straight and gay have died in the past
40 years of AIDS I remember how ignorant
I was in the beginning of this pandemic
as to what caused it our society when
you compare it to Europe in terms of sex
education down to the elementary school
is basically backwards I was in
Netherlands in 2004-2005 several times
examining educational systems like that
what do you make of that kind of aspect
of it the fact that kids in our society
are we have uneven levels of sex
education at the most basic level that
creates lack of awareness about these
issues that can create infection that we
see happening today well I think you
make an excellent point a denial that
individuals are having sex at a certain
age has been proven to be completely off
the mark by the amounts of unwanted teen
pregnancies I mean that's just proof
positive of that when you want to start
educating young people about sex you
have to educate them before they start
having sex and I think the denial in a
somewhat puritanical society of when
people start having sex usually makes us
about three or four years too late in
the process so if you're suggesting that
we should have and should now intensify
sexual education sex education among
youth the answer is absolutely that
isn't the only thing that's going to get
us out of this because a lot of what
goes on now particularly in this country
has to do with lack of access to people
who are most at risk
it has to do it you know indirectly with
sex education but you've got to remember
that early on in the beginning began and
this is sad because of the awareness of
stigma and the sensitivity of being
politically correct and not singling out
a group we said and I can go back and
even find some advertisements that say
that aids is an equal opportunity
employer that's bull AIDS is not an
equal opportunity employer if you're a
coed in Iowa and having sex with the guy
down the hall the chances of your
getting infected are infinitely less
than if you're a 16 year old
african-american girl in the Bronx
having sex with her boyfriend and that's
just the way it is so if you want
prevention you got a target populations
and you got to have the people who can
who are credible to the population out
there you don't need me a white guy in a
suit going to the Bronx educating people
about how to avoid infection you need
the community to get involved with that
anyway sorry for preaching but that's
the way I feel thanks a lot for that um
this is actually a follow-up on that on
the last question and it's really about
the sort of neglected stepchild of
behavior change programs which you
didn't talk about that much for example
you talked about the treatment as
prevention trial it's actually in the
African sites as I understand it of that
trial about half the infections were
actually that occurred in those sites
were actually do two concurrent
partnerships in those in the population
and obviously treatment is prevention
too much to affect that no that's
actually my interrupt is just for a
second that treatment as prevention is
when you treat an infected that's right
that was from that Co identify soil I
don't understand what you mean that it
doesn't work any treated person
regardless of who that person is if you
treat them you're gonna decrease their
chance for sure but you'd have to
blanket the entire hiv-positive
population including those who are of
course no no you're absolutely right if
you wanted in and of itself to decrease
the epidemic we don't have the resources
to blanket the entire population so
that's not gonna work alone sure I'm
just saying that as a scientific fact
when you treat an infected person you
make that person extremely unlikely to
infect someone else so whether we have
the resources to penetrate entire
populations is an entirely different
question yeah I was just addressing the
scientific credibility of that approach
great I just have but I actually have a
question I wonder which is which is
really I didn't mean to get sidetracked
on that of course it works you reduce
viral load you reduce transmission we
know that we know that we've known that
since about mother to child transmission
which works the same way of course no
question about that but we do know that
there are now nine studies using genetic
linkage and other techniques that show
that multiple concurrent partnerships in
other words most infections or a
significant fraction of infections in
Africa are actually happening in clearly
defined couples that we actually have
this but that multiple concurrent
partnerships in particular are
responsible for a large amount of the
spread and yet there are very few
interventions which actually address
this particular behavior when you talk
about targeting this is extremely
important and there have been no with
one except there have been no randomized
trials of interventions that address
this behavior except for one which is as
yet unpublished and actually reduced
rates of genital warts in this country
in a small trial by about fifty percent
and I just wondered you know it would be
great if there was some scientific
attention to this because we do know
that behavior change works historically
it's saved millions of lives in this
country in the 1980s for example when in
Africa and in Thailand and elsewhere in
the past and and it needs more
scientific attention and I hope that NIH
will yeah well yes ni HSN national
institute of mental health of doing
studies to try and understand the
dynamics of concurrent sexual partners
and how to interrupt it that is a really
tough nut to crack because you're
dealing with societies in which that's
embedded in the culture of the society
but they need to know those rich sure of
course is of course a point i no one
would deny that right hi that was a
great talk and it was it's wonderful to
see the whole kind of perspective
everything you've kind of laid out a
playbook for parades of what we need to
do to contain it and it's got this
history that going back 30 years of this
perspective woody what is the plan so
what my question is it makes sense for
new infections infects emerging diseases
that might be coming like a SARS or or
other pandemics does na i ad now have
kind of an accepted playbook of what's
going to be so we don't have to make all
the mistakes that we've done in the past
and in the absence of not understanding
of disease or something that's newly
emerging yeah the playbook is really a
sign if you look at the science that has
evolved over the last 20 years
particularly the last ten years when you
think of emerging diseases there's
different types obviously as you're well
aware i mean a respiratory infection
that spreads through no aspect of
conduct of behavior it just spreads is a
different story than something like
hiv/aids but one of the things that we
have been stressing now is something
that isn't NIH is mostly cdc into a
lesser extent wh 0 is surveillance
technologies that actually can detect
trends and disease that may not
necessarily be noticed by finally
somebody reporting a new disease if
there was a way and they're always you
know obviously informatics ways to do
that the other is the extraordinary
power of identification of microbes by
essentially getting around the standard
way of having to grow a microbe in a
particular culture so that if there is
somebody who's sick with something that
is unidentified we have the capability
by very high throughput deep sequencing
to be able to put together a good
assembling of what that microbe is that
we never ever had before so rather than
isolating growing developing a vaccine
you could sidestep that very very easily
so when you say playbook you know the
PlayBook gets rewritten and the thing
we've learned about emerging diseases be
it the flu or the scare of anthrax is to
be completely transparent and say what
you don't know when you don't know it
and don't let the public you know get
start guessing about things because
particularly when you have an acute
thing I me aids is very different
because AIDS was insidious aids had over
at the time that those five patients are
identified there were hundreds of
thousands of people already infected an
acute respiratory emerging infection is
a bit different you hand a little bit
different right hi thanks so much for
speaking with us today I just had a
question I'm you said in your concluding
remarks about how you know the activist
organizations have been pressuring for
the change in the 80s in terms of how
age is being addressed and that you guys
can I needed to put the pressure on
again in order to look at the Paul the
science that exists and then apply it so
I was wondering if you're then implying
but activist organizations today are not
doing as much as they have in the past
and if so why you think that change has
been and what the role of activist
organizations has been in defining risk
for HIV
you need well well certainly you know it
depends on activism is taken on
different flavors I mean the activists
of the 80s are now very sophisticated
activists in a different way so there is
a big activist movement to get resources
to implement particularly in the
developing world what we know will work
that's the great frustration that I try
to convey on the last two slides you
know anybody can be an activist I try to
be an activist within the confines of
maintaining credibility you know Larry
Kramer used to tell me Tony what you
really need to do is to chain yourself
to the White House gate well you know if
I chained myself to the White House gate
that's the last time I'll ever get near
the White House and the fact that I get
into the White House a lot I do a hell
of a lot more good than being a 15
minute hero of chaining myself so there
are activists who within the system
there are activists at wh 0 and there
are also the typical street activists
who are really putting a lot of pressure
what the pressure i'd like to see is
we're in a very difficult time of fiscal
constraints I mean you you know you just
stay awake for a couple of weeks and
look at what's been going on in our own
country the other countries aren't any
better but we have to put the pressure
that despite fiscal constraints we can't
forget about this problem we have six
million people on therapy nine million
additional people should be on therapy
given the state of their disease and
that's the reason why I stress the
treatment as prevention we're not going
to we don't have the resources or even
the logistics to get to everybody that's
infected but we know that every time you
treat somebody that person is not going
to infect anybody else another thing you
could do is every mother who comes into
a clinic in a developing nation should
be treated for HIV if they're infected
not just given a dose of nevirapine and
then say goodbye and then a dose to the
baby but
every mother should be fully treated for
the rest of her life now I feel very
strongly about that we don't have the
resources to implement about that but
the more people like myself and others
say that and say that we almost have a
moral obligation to do that sooner or
later people will listen you know my
experience in Washington is I have never
gotten something that I was pushing for
the first time I asked it just doesn't
happen you got to be a real pain in the
neck and come back over and over again
you know you've clearly shown that
treatment as prevention works and I'm
wondering if you can speak to the
history of that we now know that works
but we didn't know that in 2001 we
didn't know that 2002 2003 we did know
that MT CT worked but we didn't know
that treatment as prevention worked and
I'm wondering in light of the fact that
in 2003 we knew that for every one
person is putting on treatment 3 4 or 5
people are becoming infected why those
are such a big push for PEPFAR 2003 to
be near exclusively on treatment and
very little on prevention um well there
was there was really a cry to take its
put it this way when you have a lot of
dying people coming into a clinic it's
really tough to say and we're not going
to treat you it just it's very difficult
to do that when we put when I put the
first model together it was fifty-five
percent treatment twenty some odd
percent prevention and 30 some odd
percent care now it's much much more
even balance between treatment and
prevention just as a as a point of fact
it's very interesting how it evolved
that treatment is prevention it evolved
even before we treated anybody because
if you look at discordant couples in a
study we did in the Rick hai district of
Uganda there was a direct highly
significant correlation between the
level of viral load and the probability
of transmitting to your sexual party
without treatment then mother-to-child
transmission came and it became very
clear that the low viral load and the
mother was linearly associated with non
transmissibility then they did the
cohort studies in Canada in Africa in
San Francisco so that the principle of
low viral load is going to result in a
decrease risk of transmissibility was
obvious but what we needed was the
randomized control trial to prove it I
mean yet to be cocky about it but I knew
what the results of 052 is going to be
before we even did it what I didn't know
is what people adhere to the treatment
and they did and they did was there any
political pressure to take money away
from prevention though in those early
years 2003 because that's the primary
critique about PEPFAR is that there's
very little money for prevention because
you don't want to work with people
marginalized populations and you can
start using it really wasn't any any
political pressure to take money away
from one of you via that was the best
judgment of the countries we really
relied on the people on the ground in
the country's what they felt was their
greatest need we weren't so ugly
American presumptuous about it to say ok
Zimbabwe you do this in okay swaziland
you do that we went in and said what do
you think that helped people the health
ministers there would be the best for
the epidemic in your country the wide
whys are not why are you working through
parallel what did that firework through
parallel tracks then and not work
through the Ministry of Health lot of
the time a lot of the implementation
well we worked on at what's called a
bilateral agreements sometimes it was
the ministry helped the thing we wanted
to stay away from I mean I designed it
but it was run at first by his name
Randy the guy's name Randy Tobias was
the first one and they asked me to get a
deputy for them and I gave him a guy who
was a fellow in my lab named Mark Bible
and mark took over and became the head
of PEPFAR and he did a spectacular job
of that and now her goosby is also doing
a great job of that
but when you say parallel do you mean I
mean a lot of the times all of these the
implementation of the treatment isn't
run necessarily run follow you know the
reason is that the president was very
very clear he didn't want to be giving
money to to unaccountable sources he
just didn't want to do that and he was
right because you know quite frankly the
Global Fund is having a lot of problem
right now with a you know inspector
general investigations about where the
money's going so this way you just go
directly to an NGO be at med songs on
front da or something like that that's
who they give the money to who are quite
reliable thank you yeah so I'm curious
given your experience with the
administrative and political as side as
well as the allocation of funds in HIV
research if you think there are any
generalized lessons for biomedical
research about what's worked really well
in choosing what research programs to
pursue and how to allocate funds
compared with other areas where it seems
like there's been a lot more tension at
the NIH like clinical oncology and how
great is there a certain specificity to
the kind of research and the kind of
development that goes on in the world of
HIV research we're dealing with virology
that makes the less the lesson is very
different from something that might be
more applicable universally or at least
to say oncology you know it it's it's a
very it's a great question and I don't
know the complete answer to it even
though I've lived through it but I can
tell you that the factors that went into
all of those resources being given to
hiv/aids were multifaceted one it was
new scary and out of control even though
cancer is a very important disease and
heart diseases there's a certain
complacency when you talk about a
disease that you can predict what the
morbidity and mortality is going to be
you know that 700,000 people a year in
this country die of heart disease
and 400,000 died of cancer you know that
it happens every year up and down the
thing with HIV is one it was completely
unclear where it was going but to the
activist community played a major major
role in getting that amount of resources
so lessons learned for others I think
the biggest lesson and I don't mean to
be simplistic about it the lesson is
when you put a lot of money into a
problem you really do get results so I
mean AIDS is the poster child of
investment you know that there are more
effective antiviral drugs for HIV than
the sum total of all antiviral drugs for
every other virus combined total that's
not an accident so that means that if
the drug companies and the public demand
really wanted it you could you could
probably get anything you want
scientifically really I make the same
argument about you know malaria and
tuberculosis I mean look at the disease
burden of malaria tuberculosis only now
that we are global in our thinking and
we don't only think provincially about
what's in the United States you go to
Africa for reasons mostly of hiv/aids
and you find out when you talk to the
people there they say oh by the way you
know 800,000 kids a dying of malaria
each year and 1.7 1.9 million people are
dying it tuberculosis so that's sort of
jolting in that thank you look okay um
I'd also really like to thank you for
your talk it was really great um so I
had a question about I don't you
mentioned at the beginning of your talk
that on people kind of accused you of
being an alarmist at the beginning of
the whole AIDS epidemic and I was just
wondering like with all of the possible
epidemics or pandemics that were facing
today with like swans bird flu is one of
the
one of the examples of that I know now
they're coming out with like a movie
about the bird flu that's like I just
saw it today I saw a pre-screening today
actually like things like that and like
local news kind of blows everything up
all these kinds of things I was
wondering what's your stance on these
kind of what what a lot of people see is
alarmist kind of takes on all of these
diseases and do you think it's really
alarmism is it is it really just like
kind of unnecessary or is it more
education and or is it even creating a
lot of the stigmas on these diseases
that we have yeah it there is a good
question but it varies from disease to
disease I mean when you're talking about
a really dramatic thing like an outbreak
of a highly contagious highly lethal flu
that's different you don't need a llama
what you need is a measured approach
because when you see the movie which i
recommend it's really a great movie
particularly if you're like Matt Damon
and who else was in that movie um marion
cotillard she's not been a third round
is that there are certain things about
Allah mysm that you've really got to be
careful of we sort of saw that in the
anthrax attack of people who were going
out and stocking up on super foxes in
and getting it stalked out from the drug
stores or even during the age five and
one when people were going out and
buying Tamiflu and the concern about
taking Tamiflu for anything and
everything that happens to you so
there's a balance of Allah mysm that's
inappropriate and the way that we try to
do that as I mentioned an answer to
another question is to be very
transparent as a public health officials
and to not be afraid of saying you don't
know the answer things get really messed
up when a reporter sticks a microphone
in front of you and ask you a question
okay we're good and you don't know the
answer and you think it's better to
guess than to say you don't know that's
a huge mistake and people have done that
they've done that with the anthrax
attack there was some guessing on the
part of public health officials it was
done with h5n1 when it was first very
scary so that's the lesson that we try
to teach ourselves we do these post
mortems in the government about what was
good at what was bad about the response
and it's pretty clear that you got to be
as transparent as possible one of the
things that's difficult in our day and
age is the blogosphere because any idiot
can say whatever they want and it goes
viral on you and then you it's kind of
tough to play catch-up on getting the
truth out that's a hint about this movie
that you can see my interest is in the
science of hiv/aids and you've always
been a bit of a scientist I think as
well as a doctor in fact you seem almost
more of a scientist and a doctor but
you've presented the material today's if
there is really no more questions or
puzzles in HIV science oh and I think
you'd probably say that that's not quite
true that's that's for sure so what what
I'm wondering is is a any kind of system
in NIAID for people to make suggestions
about where you might have things wrong
a sort of red team you know how security
now they have these red team's of of
script writers who suggest possible
dangers and they deal with possible
threats in that way things they might
not otherwise think of it's a road team
at the niaid or are you somehow a king
to whom the coaches don't dare mention
anything which might disagree with what
you say I'm treated with a phenomenal
degree of disrespect the lay institute
about that now we're through an open
society there no we do an awful lot of
outreach to the scientific community the
granting process itself is a built-in
system for good ideas the ro1 process of
people putting interesting ideas in and
getting peer reviewed but in addition to
that we continually have workshops of
trying to figure out what the best
approach is it is clearly an ideas
driven process as opposed to a king
dictating what gets done that in fact is
antithetical to what science is well mal
de sauc by the way I'm a pretty good
doctor to been good and I just lost what
are the things which was still puzzled
about which haven't solved yet what kind
of things are we still wrestling with to
see how they work or okay let me tell
you what the real thing that that gives
me headaches that we don't know the body
does not make an adequate immune
response against HIV this is
unprecedented in the history of any
microt so if you look at a vaccines that
we've made that we're successful this is
critical because this is so unique that
people don't appreciate how unique it is
so take smallpox polio measles three big
killers and mainers smallpox measles
doesn't kill a lot but in some
developing countries it kills a certain
percent the interesting news is that a
vast majority of people make an adequate
immune response to clear the virus so
when we develop a vaccine we've already
have a proof of concept that the body is
capable of making
adequate immune response that not only
would clear the virus but we'll leave
you with lifelong protection
astoundingly that is not the case with
HIV the body does not make an adequate
immune response there is not one single
case that has been documented among the
60 million people have been infected
where somebody gets infected gets
established disease and completely
eliminates the virus from their body so
we are have a real problem that the big
tenant of Indian of vaccine ologist
which Steve will tell you is mimic
natural infection and you'll get a great
vaccine the one thing you don't want to
do with HIV is mimic natural infection
with a vaccine because natural infection
doesn't work so we have an enormous
challenge of how to get the body induce
the body to make a response that's even
more powerful than the natural response
that's the one scientific issue that I
think is the holy grail of HIV signs
thank you thank you very much so
throughout your presentation you've
discussed the necessity of continuing
implementation of treatment and
prevention measures against HIV and also
you mentioned briefly the restrictions
on resources that you're working with
today so I was wondering if you could
shed some light on where you think the
funds to treat those six million people
who are already on ARVs and the 91
million people out there who you already
haven't found and treated where do you
think those funds are going to come from
and how are you going to distribute them
and do you see any new fields I you just
talked about a new scientific question
or the big unanswered scientific
question in the field do you see or you
think that you'll divert resources into
answering that question or do you want
to continue continue to focus money
expenditures on the treatment and
prevent
that we already have so far those
measures my responsibility as the
director of a research program to
develop drugs and develop vaccines and
develop Diagnostics I get involved in
the policy because of the nature of my
position about people in high places
come to me and say what is it that you
think we should be doing and we do it as
a team it isn't like one person dictates
it it's it's it's a team so you said
where those resources going to come from
that's a really good question I don't
know because particularly now it's a
really really bad time but the fiscal
constraints but I got some ideas if you
look at the amount of money that's
pledged to the Global Fund by other
nations and how much they actually put
into it they don't give anything there
are more major European countries who
don't put a penny into the Global Fund
china is spending billions of dollars in
building up things in Africa in order to
have I think an economic impact and
inroads in Africa they haven't put a
penny into treatment of Africans now I
know I'm going to get in trouble
somebody's going to email the Chinese
embassy and I'm going to be spending my
next day answering emails just kidding I
don't really care but that's that's the
chai mean those are the things that we
need to do please join me in thanking a
photographer remarkable
I